let's tackle some exercises with picture
graphs and once again i'm using the khan
academy exercises to do this so it says
which towns had fewer sunny days than
sparkle city in june
alright so
if we look at the pictograph down here
each picture of a sun represents six
sunny days and we want to say which
towns had fewer
what did they say fewer sunny days in
sparkle city in june
so sparkle city is this one right over
here and sparkle city had let's see we
have one two three four five pictures of
a sun each of those represent six sunny
days so five times six sparkle city had
30 sunny days
in june so which of these had fewer than
30 sunny days
well you can just look at the pictograph
itself and all of sunville shiny town
and star village they don't have as many
of these pictures of the sun so they all
had fewer sunny days we actually don't
even have to calculate how many sunny
days each of these represent although if
you cared this would be 4 times 6 this
would be 24 this would be 2 times 6 or
12 and this would be 3 times six or
eighteen sunny days in june but all
three of them sunville shinytown and
star village sunville shiny town and
star village all had fewer sunny days in
sparkle city in june let's keep going
let's do a couple more of these
the graph shows how many mice a farmer
found in her field each day for five
days
which day did the farmer find the same
amount of mice as on wednesday and
thursday combined all right let's look
at this
so each picture of a mouse
represents two mice
see on wednesday and thursday combined
there's two ways to think about this on
wednesday and thursday combined i have
one picture of a mouse and then two more
pictures of mice so that's a total of
three pictures of mice so what other day
do i have three pictures of mice well
tuesday i have three pictures of mice so
i could just pick tuesday
now another way to think about it is on
wednesday the actual number of mice that
were observed one picture means two mice
so two mice on wednesday
four mice on thursday because i have two
pictures each of them represent two mice
so two on wednesday four on thursday so
six total and you see on tuesday we have
six mice were observed once again each
of these pictures represent two so two
four six
so there you go
all right
let's keep going
fun land had blank millimeters less
rainfall than happyville in august
so this right over here
this is fun land this is happyville and
each little raindrop picture represents
six millimeters
so funville has two raindrop pictures
happyville has four raindrop pictures so
fun land had two less raindrop pictures
so had two less of these raindrops so
two less raindrops would be two times
six it would be twelve
twelve millimeters less rainfall than
happyville another way you could have
thought about it fun land had 12
millimeters of rainfall in august
because each of these 6 then 12 each of
these represent 6 millimeters
happyville had
6 12 18 24 millimeters so 12 millimeters
versus 24 millimeters well fun land is
going to have 12 millimeters less 12
millimeters is 12 less than 24
millimeters